imagine I have a beautiful tree that's
filled with oranges and I asked myself
what is the orange made of how do I
answer that question well I want to look
deeply inside the orange so I magnify it
and I magnify it again and if I keep on
doing it
deep inside sooner or later I begin to
see molecules come into view
but molecules are not the end of the
story because the molecules I can
enlarge them and if I make them big
enough deep inside I begin to see atoms
atoms are not the end of the story too
because we have electrons zooming around
the nucleus deep inside mostly empty
space in the atom but deep inside we see
the nucleus so if I grab that and
magnify it I see that the nucleus is
itself made of particles neutrons and
protons and if I grab one of the
neutrons and magnify it
I find yet further particles little tiny
quarks inside now that is where the
conventional idea stopped strength
Theory comes along and suggests that
inside these particles there is
something else so if I take a little
quark and I magnify it conventional idea
says there's nothing inside but string
theory says I'll find a little tiny
filament a little filament of energy a
little string like filament and just
like the string on a violin I pluck it
and it vibrates creates a little musical
note that I can hear the little strings
in string theory when they vibrate they
don't produce musical notes they produce
the particles themselves
so what quark is nothing but a string
vibrating in one pattern an electron is
nothing but a string vibrating in a
different pattern a neutrino nothing but
a string vibrating and a different
pattern still so if I take all of this
back together
I have my ordinary orange and if these
ideas are right they are speculative but
if they are right deep inside the orange
or any other piece of matter there's
nothing but a dancing vibrating cosmic
symphony of strings that's the basic
idea of string theory
[Music]